I'm Rick Levin I'm the president of the
University and I one time was a member
of the ill Economics Department I
suppose officially I still am but I'm
really delighted to be here tonight with
my colleagues from the Economics
Department and some who were jointly
appointed with the School of Management
to talk about the current state of the
economy you know it's been three years
just a little over three years since the
failure of Lehman Brothers led to the
precipitous decline in the stock market
and the contraction of credit throughout
the economy the problems had already
started as predicted by Professor Robert
Shiller about about a year earlier with
it where the overinflated housing prices
have been a consequence of a very
liberal credit expansion began to fall
putting banks in trouble uh investment
banks first commercial banks followed
causing a real run from those assets
causing Bear Stearns to be rescued in
the spring of 08 em but then the Fed
unable to pressure II unable to figure
out a way to save lehman brothers from
collapsing which led them to a
precipitous decline the recession
actually started in terms of loss of GDP
it actually started a little before that
but we went into a very severe recession
which as you know has led to
persistently high unemployment a really
unusual circumstance in this country to
have unemployment linger as high as nine
percent for a three year period this the
simple um you know the simple chronology
is that we tried to save the financial
sector major banks were in fact we're in
fact rescued uh we we however did not
succeed in giving enough stimulus to the
economy to get the to get GDP back on
track and jobs and jobs reestablished
just to give a sense of perspective in
the third fourth quarter of two thousand
eight China lost one-third about thirty
percent of its total export sentence
after all on export-dependent economy
China enacted in that that winter in the
early 2009 a stimulus package equal to
15
% of its gdp almost all directly focused
on creating jobs the United States in
February of 2009 enacted a stimulus
package of six percent of GDP two-thirds
of it directed to tax cuts which had
very little impact and one-third of it
directed to the creation of jobs so
while China was putting fifteen percent
on on job creation we put two percent of
GDP toward creation of jobs consequence
china's gdp grew by nine and a half
percent in 2009 ours declined it's very
simple analysis but it makes the point
we've been we did not step up very fast
in moving toward a solution and
consequently we had persistent
unemployment we want to talk about this
tonight and there are many other factors
that the panelists will address but
we're going to talk about this tonight
because because the issue is again and
on a lot of people's minds and I will be
complete straightforward the fact that
we now are seeing public protests about
the commitment the condition of the
economy I think compels us as a
university and a teaching institution to
talk about the issues that are raised by
these protests I mean the Occupy Wall
Street movement is unhappy with
unemployment unhappy with the
distribution of income in the United
States unhappy with many aspects of the
way the financial crisis the economic
crisis has been dealt with and so we
thought it would be instructive and
useful for this community to try to have
an intelligent thoughtful discussion of
these issues so I'm gonna ask each of
the panelists to open up with with with
some opening statements we'll have a
little bit of discussion among the panel
and then we'll open up for questions
from the audience my colleagues include
Professor William Nordhaus sterling
professor of economics he's been a
member of the economics department
faculty since nineteen sixty seven Bob
Shiller a professor of economics also
finance at the School of Management the
Arthur oaken professor he has been along
now 30 years I guess on our fact we come
at 81 baba can't remember yeah something
like that 1981 30 years on the Yale
faculty June Chevalier is
faster primarily in the School of
Management also in the Department of
Economics she's the really mess by Nicki
professor she is a she was a Yale
undergraduate actually saw was Professor
Nordhaus and she's and she came back to
you in 2001 to teach her Alice Sowinski
is the only one here it didn't in some
way learned his macro economics at Yale
he he was trained in Russia and Belarus
and then did his PhD at university of
minnesota went to Harvard we were the
lure him here from Harvard just 2008 I
guess just just three years ago and john
g an accomplice the james tobin a
professor of economics was also a Yale
undergraduate class of 75 and and joined
the Yale faculty five years later after
completing a PhD at Harvard so actually
the James Tobin names an interesting one
Bob Shiller has actually done a piece
about the influence of macro economist
at Yale and I think for most of us on
this panel he's the person that probably
would have understood this crisis better
than any of any better than any of us
did um but we'll give it a shot so I'm
going to start with Professor nordhaus
good evening it's it's a great pleasure
to be here with this panel just about
three years since we were in this room
discussing exactly the same subject I I
actually want to talk about the
occupation movement I'll start with that
but then i'm going to move gradually
toward economics so New Haven is will be
occupied in the next few days joining
wall street boston LA and many other
cities i think many people are asking
should we sympathize with this should we
criticize it should we be fearful should
we be hopeful so here are some things
that some reflections I had is I thought
about those questions today well first
it is clear that protests are a very
important part of political life here
and around the world in America the
first protest was actually the pueblo
revolt in 1680 against the spanish it
ended badly when about a decade later
the Spanish came back and slaughtered
the Indians and that was the beginning
of a terrible chapter in American
history the modern era has seen
successful protests such as the civil
rights movement Yale was very much
involved in that in particularly in the
Freedom Rides just just 50 years ago to
the consternation of many of our alumni
I must say but I think at least if our
alumni were cheering us on the history
was the protests of the 1960s were also
very much part of the current new haven
seen New Haven actually we were occupied
in 1970 very much in the for roughly a
week
I was a very powerful experience for
many people who were here that ended not
well or badly but in a kind of circus in
a courtroom in Chicago and one other
president one other movement i might
mention is the native presidential
movement in 2000 which ended in the
election of George W Bush which was
surely not what the members of that
movement intended so the lesson here I
think is a kind of first lesson about
protest movements which is just to be
careful when you get on that train just
make sure who you are going on with you
know who you with and where you're going
and whether there's a coherent strategy
now symbols are very important to go
back to the 1960s there was a movement
called the students for a Democratic
Society I thought that's a pretty good
name I mean who can be against students
who can be against democracy and I
suppose most of us are for society as
well so it didn't have much to do with
the movement except that we're some
students involved but I let's think
about the brand name here the brandy not
occupy is kind of a problem when I think
occupy the first thing that comes to
mind to me is the West Bank and the
second thing is Iraq and those are not
very pleasant associations so it's a
kind of cute idea for ten seconds but I
think it's very bad politics to tell
people you're about to occupy their city
so what about the substance well I here
i have to say at least their heart is in
the right place or at least their heart
is where my heart is the basic point of
the movement is that the top 1% control
the lives of the other 99 percent and I
think there's a lot of justice here now
since we're an academic environment I'll
have to say that the numbers here are
somewhat in precise and we have to
actually look at some of the footnotes
and maybe it's not exactly one percent
but the basics are pretty clear the top
1% have about forty percent of the
wealth the top 1% can buy access to
politicians the top 1% can distort
science by creating bogus think tanks
the top 1% can fly their factotums
around the country on Learjets to make
their points the top 1% can distort the
regulatory system and under vine
environmental laws the top 1% can
confuse people into thinking that
raising tax rates will lower tax
revenues the top 1% can attack the red
Federal Reserve and pretend that
economic expansion is producing a great
inflation so there's a lot of justice
even if it's not exactly one percent and
even if it's a little more complex
there's a lot of justice in their views
but even if they are right on the
ethical fundamentals it's not going to
get very far without well-designed
policies so what are the policy
proposals of the occupation well for
those of you who would like to find out
there it's actually assuming it's not a
bogus bogus publication there's
something a publication called the
occupied Wall Street Journal okay that's
right the occupied Wall Street Journal
and if you look very carefully at the
occupied Wall Street Journal you'll find
the statement of the General Assembly of
the occupied New York movement so there
are about 20 points there I won't go
over all of them but basically it's a
manifesto against the corporate world
which is accused of torturing animals
endangering our lives with faulty
products poisoning our food supply
stealing the houses from homeowners
through foreclosures perpetrating
colonialism and many other
these deeds well they're probably some
truth in these but I think as a
political platform it's basically
splintered politics why not criticize
the Tea Party which is not a corporation
why not criticize the Supreme Court
which is not a corporation why not
criticize the filibuster which is not a
corporation why not criticize the laws
which create corporations which are not
corporations so i think it's it's a
little puzzling but that's maybe just
the beginning but it's a interesting way
to begin the movement so maybe this this
particular focus mrs. the major issues
today which are the economic issues so
the US and is in the fourth year of a
long and deep recession using the
unemployment rate as a standard we have
10 million fewer jobs than we did in
2007 there's no end in sight there are
no credible solutions in Washington so
people are quite justified in being
upset and protesting but i think the
protests need to have a coherent
strategy so what what what are the
coherent strategies well there are the
same ones that we probably would have
proposed three years ago first we need a
major and sustained fiscal stimulus
monetary policy as they say has run out
of bullets and we really have nothing in
our toolkit but fiscal policy President
Obama is right here but I think his
proposal is too modest we need to do
what he's proposed but we need it for a
sustained period of time so I would say
the jobs bill times three second we need
to stop attacking the Federal Reserve
the Fed has been on the side of
expansion since the beginning it's got
somebody at the top who understands the
situation and we need to encourage the
Fed to keep up its work on financial
stimulus the attacks on the Fed are not
only part us are not only partisan but
also ignorant return to the gold
standard give me a break we're not in
Kansas this is an integrated world
economy shut down the Fed or in the
title of the book and the Fed give me a
break no major country and I don't even
know if a minor country today of all the
countries around the world with all
their political systems from everything
from democracy to autocracy to
dictatorship all around the world north
and south big and small every country
has a central bank money cannot manage
it itself now I don't want to be
dogmatic so we have an econ students
here yay so I would say anyone who wants
to defend return to the gold standard or
abolishing the central bank come on over
to econ 122 and we'll have a discussion
third in the long run we have to pay for
these in ways but in ways that reduce
inequality and the long run means when
we're back at full employment not this
year so how about a carbon tax to both
meet revenue needs and our commitments
on climate change how about raising tax
rates on high-income households for
example by allowing the high-income Bush
tax cuts to expire at the end of 2012
and to have a new proposal on the table
why don't we follow the suggestion of
Bruce Ackerman of the Yale Law School to
levy wealth is wealth taxes on high
wealth Americans now lest you think this
is a radical long-haired left-wing SDS
type idea I would remind you that
Western Europe does this
has less wealth inequality and also has
pretty good pasta so there are many
other steps that are necessary in the
political arena well I'll leave those
for another day and for other people in
the near term however the economic these
economic steps are critical to make
America a place that is livable for the
99 percent whose economic situation is
stressed and who are disenfranchised for
making the decisions that would improve
it thanks
just to verify one point when Bill
nordhaus was a young professor at Yale
in 1970 when I came to graduate school
he did not have long hair he did not he
did not wear visible manifestations of
any kind of protest movement he looked
like a straightforward clean-cut Yale
graduate who was a hard-working
professional okay net what I'm not going
to describe myself he probably will in X
time he gets the mic up Bob Shiller
well I'm fond of quoting it was Paul
Romer who said every crisis is an
opportunity and i think that i took this
crisis which began almost five years ago
as an opportunity and since then i've
written or co-authored four books about
the crisis and now i have 10 minutes the
talk but in addition i remind you that
the dodd-frank act was passed 848 pages
and the American Jobs Act which
President Obama initiated 362 pages so
it's a little bit hard I'll speaking
just points of generality I think that
when we go through a crisis like this
it's a time for us to improve everything
that I think dodd-frank was right to
have so many details in it and I think
the general trend should be toward
improving and extending our financial
markets making them work better as
financial markets they have a
fundamental function in our society but
making them work better means to me
democratizing and humanizing them and so
that's what we have to do and we've
taken some steps for example the
Consumer Financial Protection Bureau
that dodd-frank created is a
democratizing and humanizing element of
Finance of a reform so I have so many
things that I could talk about I thought
that since you mentioned jobs and since
the American Jobs Act was just the
filibustered and shot down we no longer
have a proposal I thought I would talk
about that I think it was a good bill
actually unfortunately it had a little
bit of redistribution in it that is
unpalatable to American
namely a five point six percent
surcharge on incomes above 1 million
dollars but let's not focus on that I
you know the thing I like to focus on is
all the good things that were in that
bill most notably it had a clear plan
for infrastructure investment all right
we've got millions of unemployed doing
nothing we could put them to work on
long-term projects this is an old idea
the American Jobs Act proposed that we
improve our airports we improve our
highways more we improve our schools and
community colleges more and that we deal
better with foreclosed properties in the
real estate market on top of that it
also proposes that we should hire back
the teachers that were laid off the
police none that were laid off the
firemen that were laid off so that was a
I think it has to be a good idea at a
time like this but it seems to have a
budgetary problem and the problem is
that the main part of the American Jobs
Act was actually a tax cut a temporary
tax cut in the form of a payroll tax cut
and that would have temporarily raised
the national debt our president said it
was fully paid for but he meant it was
fully paid for over 10 years so that
didn't sit well going further into debt
for a while so I thought I just wanted
to talk about how we really could do the
stem good part of that stimulus so I
suggest that we go back with title 2 and
title for of the JOBS Act which title 2
is the infrastructure investment part
and title for is a tax increase on the
wealthy but not it could be tweaked and
modified but if we did those two things
that's hiring back the teachers and
building the schools and that sort of
thing it would be a balanced budget
expenditure increase we seem to have
this idea that any stimulus has to
involve raising the national debt I've
written three newspaper columns in one
article about this fallacy it's not true
there's something called the balance
budget multiplier which says especially
under conditions like this when we are
in near depression it says that an
increase in government expenditure
matched by taxes will have a
approximately 14 1 increase in in the in
the budget this theory was developed by
Walter assailant and Paul Samuelson in
the 1940s I poll economists not younger
economists have never heard of this but
that's my immediate proposal to get jobs
back thank you
Thanks okay so um I thought I would take
a couple minutes to talk about the top
one percent since the Occupy Wall Street
movement has you know focuses itself on
the bottom ninety nine percent and
against I guess the top one percent so I
thought I would say a little bit about
that you probably know but I'll just
review what we know about the top 1% the
share of total I mean perhaps one of the
things that you know incite anger about
the top 1% is the share of total income
attributable to the top 1% was pretty
much declining over the first half of
the 20th century and then around
nineteen seventy started increasing and
has been increasing pretty pretty
steadily since then so bill mentioned
the share of wealth attributable to the
top 1% that's even larger the share of
income attributable to the top 1% of
income earners was about nine percent in
1970 and stands somewhat north of twenty
percent today so that's a big change
over you know a third of 40 40 year
period and I should note that that you
know upward trend is you know fairly
constant if you look at the data even
though the tax rate on the top bracket
started at fifty percent went to
twenty-eight percent went to thirty-nine
percent went to thirty-five percent so
that kind of upward movement in the top
one percent of income has been you know
considering continuing and kind of
accelerating since the 1970s and so I
think that that leads a lot of people to
you know first of all think about tax
issues but also think about you know
will what is wrong that this you know
top 1% keeps getting richer and richer
where whereas incomes of you know
Americans below you know the median
American has pretty much stagnated and
now has declined you know a lot of
people point some things that people
point to that I think are worth thinking
about a little bit our CEOs and
executives and managing directors at
final financial services for
they account for some share of these of
these highly paid individuals certainly
not all of them there's some you know
evidence in paper by Steve Kaplan and
Joshua that CEOs maybe account for about
three percent of the top one percent of
income earners so so it's a rough
estimate since no one has their tax tax
returns but you know so there's a lot of
anger directed I think at this top one
percent and there's probably you know
there's a significant amount of research
asking the question about why this
widening income disparity has taken
place especially in financial services
and for CEOs I should point out that
CEOs I didn't get a lot of attention
though you know in 2009 the entire
fortune 500 CEOs made about a sixth of
the total income that the top 25 hedge
fund managers made so there's there's
even CEOs or kind of second-class
relative to the relative to financial
services and you know there are
provisions even in dodd-frank to try to
you know address these issues and
regulate these issues so many of you
probably know that dodd-frank has these
say-on-pay provisions which requires
shareholder votes on executive
compensation packages and you know so
far those mostly took effect this year
this last year of annual annual meetings
and you know about 2% of the pay
packages were actually voted down at
these shareholder meetings so that
regulation you know may have some you
know effects at the very tail and very
you know extreme circumstances but you
know really isn't going to take on you
know CEO pay I think kind of a more
interesting question is you know do we
you know should the 99 percent be
focused on the you know extraordinary
income being earned by the one percent
you know certainly it when we think
about taxation they should be but there
seems to be a lot of anger about the
level of pay and certainly research you
know some of this increase
and pay is probably good if you look
prior to the 1970s not only was CEO pay
lower but it was also much less
incentive based and if there was much
less disparity across CEOs all of which
probably points to greater paper for
performance and you know that's probably
a good thing but we haven't really you
know when you think about these reforms
you know so if the 99 percent rate rises
up and manages to you know put put some
regulations in place that that lower the
incomes of the one percent will that
actually have any effect what will that
have an effect on I mean it's probably
true that if CEOs are overpaid that you
know if shareholders managed to rein
that in that would improve the welfare
of shareholders and there are a lot of
shareholders in the 99 percent but what
does that have to do with you know jobs
or job creation in the rest of the
economy and I think the answer is not
really all that much so you know it's
not i think you know those of you who
have thought about economics probably
understand this but I think it's worth
spelling out that you know it's not like
your house where if you spend more money
on cookies you're going to spend less
money on cereal or something else I mean
if the if if CEO pay was cut and that
really was profitable that would
increase profits but that really doesn't
have a logical connection to therefore
we're going to raise the pay on
everybody else or create jobs for
everybody else we really need if we're
going to have job creation we need you
know some of these reforms may be good
but we need plans for job creation that
don't that are separate from these kind
of attempts at curbing any abuses that
may be present among the one percent
well let me just maybe start talking
about what worries me in general with
the economy of the United States there
is a tendency now to talk about today
now the crisis the horrible situation
that we are in now but let's compare say
even a large crisis a crisis that leads
to ten percent loss of gdp to just the
one percent slowdown of growth over say
20 years say well it's rare it doesn't
really happen but we do see situations
like as we see Japan think about Japan
in 1989 it was a real powerhouse which
many people thought it would be number
one at dominated but would dominate the
world economy and 20 years after after
the laws decay actually the last two
decades of economic growth nobody really
talks about the Japan maybe except for
there isn't very unfortunate events with
the earthquake but it's off the economic
map of the world to large extent this
doesn't generate as much excitement so
the focus on the crisis and what to do
about the crisis i think overshadows a
much bigger problem the long-term
economic growth and I'm afraid that we
are on the verge of something much
bigger and much more problematic with
the US economy and it's the lost Decatur
and two decades of growth so think about
the jobs in in the US so why is the
unemployment so high if you look
actually at unemployment in the recent
crisis in the US vs unemployment in
Europe the US singularly stands out in
terms of how badly it fares in terms of
the labor markets so why are the
business is no fire and why is that
employment so high yes it's a present
issue no one in 10 American Americans is
unemployed that means it's your cousin
it's your brother it's your neighbor but
why the firm's not hiring and part of it
actually it has to do with the failure
of
policy and the expectations about what's
going to happen with the US economy
think about you know it was a talked
here about the fiscal stimulus in this
fiscal stimulus work I don't think so
you know at least a large body of
economic research shows that large
increase in government spending to
ascertain the Second World War I said it
in the during the Korean War the
multiplier cannot be more than one maybe
it's a little bit more than one but
probably if you if I had to hold my hat
on fire the multiplier is about 14 1
percent increase in government spending
so you get one percent increase in GDP
so what wind up with wind up with
significantly higher debt we end up with
giant unemployment we will end up with
lackluster performance of the economy so
now think about the businesses think
about the households somebody has to pay
for this debt when it's the future
generations who gonna pay its you know
you have to pay next year you have to
pay in 10 years this money have to come
out of somewhere so this certainly slows
down today's economic decisions on
whether to hire workers or not the
second thing is then certainty about
economic policy many things have been
has been said here I will really
reversion to the European system within
flexible flexible labor markets with
much higher government regulations with
you know that all the regulated ossified
financial markets and let's look at the
performance of of Europe the bill said
that Europe is a wonderful place with
great pasta but I also would like to
remind you that the unemployment in
spain and italy mon youth is twenty-five
percent this this thing can easily
happen in the ass is the US economic
system turning into potential over the
long run something that looks much more
like europe of the regulated slow growth
ossified economy another thing which
vexes me about the discussion of the
crisis is that we're moving away from
two things i learned as an economist
which are important to me
I think about the government policy the
first thing is not what we can do but
where markets fail now and it's
understandable you know the station is
very bad for many Americans they put a
lot of political pressure on the
politicians to act but instead of asking
what to do now one has to ask where the
markets fail the second thing I think
it's very important what what Professor
earlier said is when we talk about
unemployment when we talk about
lackluster growth it's very important to
think again about not indirect ways how
to fix the economy but one thing which
is important i want i want i would like
to keep in mind is direct transfers and
direct policies are always better than
this sir culus indirect very blunt
instruments so if you want to talk about
them unemployment let's talk about
unemployment what does this have to do
necessarily with tax in top 1% what does
have to do with the occupy the wall
street movement so I think the
overarching objective that this country
should have is long-term economic growth
and failure to do so I think we'll have
significant the more profound effects on
the well-being of everybody unemployment
on rate of growth on incomes then
anything that one can deal with you know
the small policies and the small fixes
that is currently proposed across the
political spectrum
so the Occupy Wall Street the Occupy
Wall Street movement has a fundamental
reason we were promised that if we
bailed out Wall Street Wall Street would
bail out Main Street and that clearly
hasn't happened the riots that we see
now I think are going to be the prelude
to bigger riots because things are going
to get could get without the right
interventions could get worse now
president Levin pointed out that I was
class of 75 at Yale that was the era
just after the riots Yale campus was
awash in riots in 1970 1971 my
generation had to live with the fact
that we missed the revolution but we may
have another chance if we're not careful
so I agree with Bob Shiller who says
quoting I guess Paul Romer I'm not sure
he was the first one to say it who says
that every crisis is really an
opportunity and a long term opportunity
I think we need to look at this crisis
as a long-term problem and not a
short-term problem so when I think of my
daily life the infrastructure is one of
the first things that occurs to me and
bothers me I mean it takes longer and
longer to drive to New York it takes
it's bigger and bigger hassle to use the
airports all over Europe they don't just
have pasta they have trains that work
they've got airports that work we have
as everyone has pointed out a huge
number of unemployed people when you pay
money to hire somebody to build a bridge
in the long run it makes money for the
economy it's not something it may be
worse for the bat short-term deficit or
short-term debt but the long run it
makes money the bridge saves people time
it makes production more efficient you
raise taxes more taxes in the long run
you actually save money it's a terrible
waste to leave people unemployed when
there's so many
projects left to do but I don't think we
should just triple the last stimulus I
think we should think to ourselves we
need a 10 or 20 year program to redo the
American infrastructure why aren't there
Blue Ribbon committees being appointed
to figure out if we're going to change
something over 10 and 20 years what is
the process we have to you know what
should we be doing it's not obvious how
to change the roads by the way once
they're set in stone as it were it's
hard to see how exactly to rearrange
them so it's a it's a it's a profound
problem which needs a lot of thought and
a long-term solution so it'll stimulate
employment in the short run but it'll be
a project that will have a big effect in
the long run so macroeconomics is also a
subject that needs long-term
improvements let's face it economists
didn't predict this crisis they didn't
predict the what would happen after the
crisis most economists including the
President's Council of Economic Advisers
they assured us that the unemployment
would never get above eight percent you
do the stimulus package it'll solve most
of the problem and maybe they had to say
that but the fact is they got it all
wrong so there's something wrong it
didn't predict the crisis and the models
after the fact still aren't very good at
explaining the crisis so we also have to
straighten out our macroeconomics now I
think that there's something missing for
macroeconomics which is and missing from
the Federal Reserve policies which is
they don't concentrate on leverage they
pay all their attention on the interest
rate whenever there's a problem the feds
supposed to lower the interest rate
whenever there's a purty know things are
getting too good they're supposed to
raise the interest rate and shockingly
lowering the interest rate didn't solve
the problem so I say well you can't
lower it before below zero as if they if
they lowered it another one percent to
negative one that would have solved the
problem the interest rate is not the
heart of the problem the heart of the
problem is that people borrow too much
money with too little collateral so if
you are a homeowner you could put one or
two percent down so you could put almost
no money down to buy a house if you
bought a mortgage security or a you know
a bond you could put almost no money
down to buy the bond so in my opinion
the thing that really caused the economy
was too much borrowing so
the Federal Reserve we should be so it
was too little money down to buy a house
too little money down to buy a security
the effect of that was that it raised
the prices of houses and raised the
prices of securities macroeconomic
theory never talked about leverage and
its effect on prices Finance has taught
us for years now we have some mavericks
on this panel but the conventional
finance teaches that prices are always
efficient market prices and they you
know their their fundamentals and so on
but you know they're around the edges of
the profession especially people on this
panel people have quibbled with that but
the fact is it's fundamentally wrong if
you allow too much leverage you can get
to high prices and when leverage
suddenly collapses because there's more
uncertainty prices are going to go down
if you have the right diagnosis of what
caused the problem you should also have
the right diagnosis of how to get out of
the problem so in the leverage cycle too
many people borrow debts go way up there
almost as high as the collateral and
then suddenly the collateral falls in
value and now people are underwater
that's the reason why we're in so much
trouble now the debts are so huge
compared to the collateral and the
wealth of people have that they can't
get out from under it if you're a
homeowner and you owe 150 thousand
dollars in your house now is only worth
a hundred thousand dollars are you gonna
pay thirty ten thousand dollars to make
a thirty thousand dollar improvement in
the house absolutely not because sounds
eventually going to take your house are
you going to move to another city to
take a job absolutely not because the
bank won't let you because you've still
got your house behind you can't sell it
and buy a new house your are you going
to hire a gardener to fix up the house
absolutely not so the situation is much
worse I think that you probably know
there are two million people who've
already been thrown out of their houses
they're going to be there five million
people more who are so far delinquent
thereafter there are 90 days or more
delinquent that they're almost surely
going to get thrown out of their houses
and if the prowess don't change three
million more households who are current
who are current at the moment are paying
are probably going to go delinquent and
be thrown out of theirs so on top of the
two million who got thrown out of their
houses we're going to eight million more
that's when the riots are going to start
so it's not just household it's also
businesses that can't there's no reason
to be productive you
get a loan if you're underwater you
don't know whether you're going to own
your own business eventually because
you're not sure whether it's going to be
taken away from you so I think that what
we need to do is to in the long run
prevent another leverage cycle like this
so dodd-frank should concentrate on
leverage and not concentrate on putting
skin in the game which is what Barney
Frank wants to do I interviewed him on
Squawk Box that's what he thinks of
banks owned everything then we wouldn't
have a problem troubles bank's own too
much stuff and that's why we got into a
problem but anyway and the last thing is
that we should come and do
infrastructure but then we should do
something about housing so I'm in favor
of writing down principal I don't have
time to explain how to do it maybe in
the questions but if you reduce it the
typical hundred sixty thousand dollar
loan if the guy's house is only worth a
hundred thousand he's a subprime
borrowers if you throw him out of the
house it takes years to get him out of
the house he doesn't pay his taxes he
doesn't pay his mortgage he ruins the
house in the end the average recovery is
less than forty thousand thirty five
thousands the typical you get back from
160 thousand dollar loan subprime loan
where you throw the guy out of the house
if you forgave the loan to 80,000
there'd be equity back in the house
you'd probably get your 80,000 and the
homeowner would stay in the house it
would be better for the homeowner and
better for the lender so that's the sort
of thing that we some of us advocated
three years ago and we should have done
now it's a little harder to do but we
should still do it and only I think with
a drastic intervention like that are we
going to prevent a worsening situation
I promised myself I wouldn't do this but
I'm going to synthesize the remarks of
all six Bill nordhaus just passed me a
note and said six economists 6 solutions
actually I don't think that's true I
think that I think everyone's right and
one of the reasons that everyone can be
right is that there's really three
different problems being addressed in
the various remarks there's the
short-term return to full employment
there's the long-term stimulus to want
to economic growth and there's and
there's the kind of relief of wealth
let's put in the first category this
short-term stimulus to the economy can
be back to work there's there's a
short-term problem of preventing further
mortgage foreclosures and their
long-term problem of stimulating
economic growth in a sustainable way and
that means including long-term fiscal
discipline so in a certain way I think
you can have all of these if we had if
we were able to have a rational dialogue
about that you can stimulate the economy
in the short run by creating jobs just
as Bob Shiller was suggesting and Bill
nor house was suggesting a stimulus x 3
that sustained for a longer time that
focuses on infrastructure which are
productive investments just as John gene
accomplice was saying those things can
that can be done it's possible it would
work we we don't have to wait five years
for a national infrastructure plan to
know that there are a lot of road crews
out there right now on the Quinnipiac
River Bridge all over the country there
there there are still even in this
depressed economy public works projects
that are underway right this very minute
you could double down you could ask the
contractors how many more workers could
you absorb on these jobs now and that
gives you at least right away possibly
as many as a million new construction
jobs if you do it if you do it carefully
and correctly and that's a and even with
a multiplier of one that's still one you
know about one percent on the reduction
in the unemployment rate so so that
that's what you can do the short run in
the long run you can develop a national
infrastructure plan Tom Friedman's been
yelling about it for years now
and it would be a very wise and smart
thing to do I think John John Jane
accomplices idea about writing down the
value of home mortgages would help to
prevent further decline in housing
prices and would help would help get
short-term stabilization and is
certainly a superior solution to
subsidizing the interest rate which
doesn't really solve the problem of
people being underwater in their
mortgages and then finally long-term we
had an unfortunate episode this last
year because we completely divorced the
question of short-term stimulus from
long-term fiscal discipline we need to
have a long-term balanced budget by the
way the federal deficit is now about
eight or nine percent of GDP something
like half of that maybe a little less
than half would disappear if we got back
to full employment half the other half
four or five percent are structural
deficit that won't disappear unless we
do something about it that's the part we
have to address you do not have to
address it today you can address it over
time and what you need now is credible
legislation that that that make puts the
entitlement programs in in a more sound
fiscal position so you you can you can
do the stimulus and at the same time say
we're going to make some modifications
to the Medicare program we're going to
do one of the many sensible things you
could do to Social Security to put that
that program in the black and and and
you could and you could begin to think
about some program of tax increase
letting the bush tax cuts expire on
schedule would be one and it doesn't
happen right away and it doesn't dampen
the recovery from recession the fact
that we that we let the politicians
divorce those two issues and talk
exclusively about deficit reduction this
summer was really a fit was really a
failure I think of both the Congress and
the executive branch should not have
happened that's my prescription I think
these things i think these problems have
a rational solution i think we saw the
elements of them displayed on this panel